on attend ce n'est pas naturel c'est
[Musique]
qu'elle accueille des maires je me casse
maman je m'excuse
ça va être franchement ça se reproduira
pas mais juste à sentir bon voilà c'est
vrai qu'en vrai c'est voulu ces deux
mots en fait non non mais c'est quoi
non mais c'est pas de leur blanche ont
fait citer comme quoi c'est du tifo côté
un peu bien sûr mais vous disais c'est
jamais non mais c'est bien mais ces
données ne sont pas que la banquette
parce que c'est pas grave on al houthi
on à l'outil internet c'est ce que le
thé tâche
oh mais c'est évident enlever une tasse
de thé sur la moquette
c'est évident s'attache à regarder mais
j'ai la meilleure blague mais tu connais
pas la chanson le quai s'attache au
conseil des droits dans les loges et de
mon côté j'ai non seulement ça mais moi
[ __ ] la série a on regarde c'est bon
c'est bon
regardez regardez les tâches de thé sont
plus résistantes que l'on peut pas
médiation je sais moi présence du groupe
au brésil présente comme ça ça va plus
vite ce week-end on est trop près
transfert à nice chi chi hauteur tu
viens en avant une de plus intendance
youtube inde et en guinée avec ce qu'ils
voulaient pas vu énorme vidéo présente
au fusil ont cru à nice tu déposes est
avesnois tendances beauté de top cops 28
des livres de rain man city
je me présente sur balles je t'ai pas
mauvais que dans nos frais du gladio et
est un auteur comédien plus hauteur que
comena entre autres ses golden stage
avant aulas avait maintenant sur la
cession youtube il travaille aussi pour
plein de choses telles que à son compte
au quotidien avec reliant treyvaux et
sur vannes il a fait 1 vannes qui
arrivait avec 62 millions de
pour ces pauvres hères arrêter d'en
parler mais ça fait vraiment très mal et
c'est à dire qu'on va on va dire à nice
dans trois ventes et c'est à dire qu'on
attend est ce qu est ce qu on peut le
mettre le même tu me donne
l'autorisation peut aller et j'envoie
guinée guinée on lui vole il est un peu
trop d'énergie en suisse ont mené et on
regarde et on regarde je passe les
chroniques
panayotis bien que ça ses modes mais pas
là aussi avec plusieurs casquettes se
trouve c'est intéressant de kehl et non
mais c'est vrai qu'il est plus complexe
qu'on le croit ouais que l'agent de
quotidiens sache que tu fais d'autres
choses c'est vrai c'est une réalité non
mais sans faire de vagues
non mais c'est vrai qu'il n'y ait aucun
blessé par la violence mais des ça
[Rires]
restait seconde partie génétique
t'imagines si ya pas encore de
génériques mais ça arrive j'image étiez
depuis j'ai eu un gros bang farage est
qu'au niveau ouvrir un peu la fenêtre
mais vraiment pas longtemps alors ferme
ta gueule du monde et surtout majine si
on restait jeune d'apparence
je verrai ça va donc là et on va
réfléchir là dessus au casque jaune
apparence ok ok d'accord tu imagines si
on restait jeunes jusqu'à la main
j'aurais plus jamais de trop
parlons ils étaient concentrés mais des
films assez concentré sa petite phrase
et pardon excusez moi rencontres
estivales avoir ce rôle m'a vas-y vas-y
allez c'est bon c'est pas grave ça c'est
rien 15 ans ok c'est bon ou non les gars
j'étais l'argent un peu sérieux danger
un peu ça tu imagines sont restés jeunes
jusqu'à la main tu vas zoom sur l'essai
java nicholas machines sont restées
vaines jusqu'à la marge aurait plus
jamais besoin de céder ma place dans le
bus elle s'appelle sita bon ben voila
c'était une balle question d'après du
coup outre des maladies on verrait pas
la mort venir genre tu es peinard en
train de marcher dans la rue dans la
fleur de l'âge et pouf tu crèves est
mort de vieillesse quand il a fait
vraiment moche non non non mais faut
qu'on commence à c'est vrai que j'en la
tuque non mais tu pour éclabousser la
mam tout de suite bien tu pourrais avoir
80 ans tu vois des débats non ce qui
l'amène à oui d'accord ok bon ça va mais
oui c'est pas la ceinture c'est qu'on a
je m'attends ou mais tu marches dans la
rue un mec jeunes peu d'un coup c'est
cool et parce qu'il fait un malaise
c'est mon rester jeunes jusqu'à sa mort
ont dû garder insensible à force de voir
crever les gens sans prévenir
non moi je vais pas d'accord fin tu vas
exemple game of thrones non je crois que
tout le monde meurt pour tenter quand
même triste j'étais pas habitués dans
les carpates habitués riquet a gagné
aussi ils sont émis mardi qui vient de
tout et c'est là que j'ai chialé
tellement les enfants mia mais voilà ça
veut dire que en fait je vois ce que je
veux dire où l'eau douce est vrai que
nos potes
ouais je vois ce qu'il va dire mais oui
c'est à dire qu'ils étaient beaucoup
moins sensible quand une personne âgée
qui meurent parce que ma visite c'est
normal a vécu son temps mais voilà que
quand un jeune tu dis merde
été foudroyé si jeune ah oui par rapport
aux quelqu'un qui est jeune témoin
choqué ok ouais ouais c'est vraiment ça
les habitués à écouter pardon à ses
vrais parents là la raison en vrai
qu'ils soient jeunes qu'ils soient vieux
ils mourraient de la même manière tu es
verrait pas tombé d'un coup c'est le
donneur humain mais tu vois un jeune
mourir en fait ça sert mais si tu
entends je sais pas qui est mort et
qu'il m'a dit tu ressembles à mais je
suis pas daccord choix parce que je
regardais sur ce que disait pas là je
pense que tu as beaucoup plus de chances
de voir des gens genre marcher dans la
rue et bim d'un coup clem c'est parce
qu'ils ont la capacité de management
gérard des vieux marché devant moi tu
tombais janvier où il meurt souvent dans
leur lit là vu que maintenant ils sont
très élevés qui vont en boîte
j'y vais on sait plus attendez mais oui
si les vieux que j'étais derrière il ya
un truc que l'on faisait que les
organismes sont fatigués donc s'ils sont
faites avec 25 ans me réjouis il a 25
ans robin des bois on se donne
rendez-vous dans deux semaines au rosé
rigide la beauté grave
allez on y va quand même ce qui n'est
pas que les pour la santé sujet avec ses
pas c'est pas grave on choisit sont
maintenant est ce que oui voilà c'est
que d'apparence ont annoncé l'avoir mais
touche aussi à des risques en gros si
non la question c'est comment on serait
si on était immortel j'invoque j'invoque
tome qui est à côté de 20 octobre sur
les quais semaine régis la régie comme
dirait la régie précise qu'on est sur
l'apparence voilà que sur la fin dépeint
sous les traits d'un cadre pour le
virage de la modernité
je rigole du coup après la juste c'est
une année vraiment sur l'apparence du
coup cyrus a juste fait une erreur voilà
ça arrive tu t'es trompé c'est juste ça
en fait si ta nea sa fermeté sur sa
réalisation mais c'est bien parce que
ses qualités suivies sur youtube et à
tort c'est bizarre c'est justin je
trouve ça un peu fou ça te combien de
temps que tu as fait ce que ça fait une
semaine que l'on se trouve moi je trouve
ça fun que ça te fait rire mais moi j'ai
l'impression de perdre mon temps je sais
pas si on devrait dire vouloir ça si on
restait jeune d'apparence d'apparence
jusqu'à la mort on aurait donc tous le
même âge ce qui est retiré les limites
sociales lié à celui ci on aurait des
potes de tout âge
manon passe comme ça c'est pas bon j'ai
connu freddy qui à 32 ans même jeu tant
dans sa tête
j'ai envie de voir 15 à 14 15 ans la
chose qui me freine quand même à
l'époque c'est que j'avais la chance de
pouvoir accéder à certaines
infrastructures où certains trucs pour
mon âge mais qui sont pas possibles
quand tu es très jeune par exemple tu
peux pas rentrer en boîte la population
qu'un bois tu peux pas la rencontrer tu
peux pas rentrer dans certains c'est
compliqué déjà pour des parents de
laisser leurs enfants prendre le rer
pour des transports d'aller à paris xe
tard donc dû coûter bloqué dans un truc
tu as ton univers est beaucoup plus
restreinte quand tu es plus d'eau dans
tous les cas c'est plus compliqué quand
tu es jeune de te faire des amis un peu
plus vieux je pense que plus tu grandis
plus certaines infrastructures s'ouvre à
3 à toi par exemple beaucoup de mecs de
20 ans s'est encore compliquée pour eux
d'aller au musée puisque c'est pas
quelque chose de très connu en battant
alors que tout le monde invente on peut
aller au musée mais c'est pas un truc
qui dans les moeurs
chez du coi à saveur et plus récement
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas aller au
skatepark marion bail mais justement
c'est pour ça que ce serait compliqué je
pense que j'avais intérêt mais tu étais
mon point de vue c'est à chaque à chaque
âge tu as des centres d'intérêt qui sont
plus ou moins commun mais qui l'on
refuse dans des mares c'est à dire qu'à
81 tirs après dans un skate park et
avant trois tons premier réflexe c'est
pas d'aller dans un musée tu as
forcément je vulgarise complètement j'ai
vulgaris complètement parce que la part
des gens qui connaissent de l'invs ont
mis les mais c'est pas des trucs qui
viennent instinctivement tu vois on vous
dira plus qu'à 20 ans est ainsi née et
cac 40 ans d'efforts qui fait un musée
où tu as je vous lis harris complètement
web on est d'accord général du prg à
seignosse n'y a pas de désaccord non
mais moi bah alors je veux pas son
modèle c'est vrai de toute l'émission
voit bien là c'est bien il pas d'accord
il n'est pas d'accord avec plus fort
mais moi si les méta il aimait taille
designer parce que je mets ce que je
voulais dire et ayez aussi ton propos
d'êtres humains il a tendance à se
rassembler avec les gens qui se
ressemblent donc y'a un truc qui se
créerait de à l'huile à 70 ans
même si d'apparence on a la même dégaine
on a traversé un nombre d'années
conséquent ensemble enfin il similaire
donc on se ressemble plus qu'un mec qui
a 20 ans même si physiquement on a la
même dégaine as tu penses que ça
prédominait j'avais un genre je pense
qu'inconsciemment ça se créerait enfin
ça
forcément j'ai exception je pense que je
me sentais la plus proche d'un mec par
exemple imagine je sais pas moi je suis
un chien et mots ouais ok on fait le
choix mauvais choix de mario lechat
je pense que je me sentais la plus
proche d'un 70 ans et mots que d'un mec
de mon âge
guy parce que le ceinturer la façon dont
ils ont la même gueule je te fait le
truc contraire - chypre
peut-être que oui mais je pense qu'à un
héros de 70 ans il sentirait pas proches
d'un et maux de ventre parce que je
dirais ok lui il a 20 ans et c'est parce
que sa quatrième en tant que module sont
alors qu'un mec oui mais le sort est
déjà de quoi qu'il avait un deal à
prendre où il habitait là voilà je parle
de à part tout le monde d'ailleurs
lorsqu'on me posez la question à chaque
fois le restant ce que l'on sait qu'ils
nous ressemblent on se pense que les
constructeurs elles et les affiliations
social à ce montage de branchement d'un
coup je pense qu'on tiendrait à
différencier et du coup quand samir est
peut-être différemment
je pense qu'un mec qui est certain
d'avoir 70 ans n'aurait pas sauf s'il a
envie de tricher à tous qui rêvait de
sawija way du cou qui auront envie
d'habiller vieux parce que généralement
quand tu vieillis tu as peur de vieillir
des environs ni dressé j'ai donc tout le
monde ne met elle pas celle d'irène ian
hart a biffé journée à table il ya tu
t'habilles à la mode devant des toiles
évoquent way we de temps l'époque mais
du coup pour les jeunes qui voient les
gens s'habiller de leur époque et qui
ont 40 ans de plus qu'eux il s'habille
comme des dieux mais donc du coup toi tu
en feras c'est bien sûr parce que tu
triches très s'adonnant au niveau de la
mer est-ce que tu triches raes qu'on
s'habille ray tous la même manière du
coup puisque noël mode de vieux est ce
que dit la presse chacun son allégeance
algerac dont des gens des malins mais
ils sont persuadés qu'ils ont 70 ans il
ya des chances que chacun savait ce
qu'il a mangé un habit comme les gens de
mon époque
ou alors ils ont envie de s'habiller
comme tous les braves gens sûrs que les
six ont tous vu il ya des chances que
les gens s'habillent comme l'âge auquel
ils se ressentent pas la chine accès
simple
par exemple toi si tu te sens comme un
mec de 40 ans tu t'habilles ray plus tôt
quand un mec de 40 ans je pense moi je
suis pas d'accord je crois pas d'accord
moi je pense qu'en fait tu sais plus
quoi dire a manqué pas d'accord je suis
pas je suis d'accord ou pas d'accord
avec le fait que je sois pas d'accord
dont tu peux a dit alain je suis pas
d'accord dans le sens où je pense que
oui il y aurait des gens qui feront ce
qu'ils veulent et qui serviront comme
déjà l'extérieur pour rester jeune dans
leur tête et dans leur jeu c'est pas
dans leur vécu
du coup ça reste souvent des jeunes peut
fumer bref mais je pense que en fait
commenté par exemple tu as vécu dans les
années 80 je reste plus attaché à la
mode des années 80 que un mec qui fait
semblant de ou qui y avait quand même
des gens qui serait authentique d'avoir
vécu dans cette époque et c'est ce qui
est à un peu et déjà maintenant quand tu
vois moi qui ai grandi dans les années
90 pourrait donc quand je vois les
jeunes comment il s'habille dans les
maintenant en mode george qui perd 1,90
c'est une caricature de commandes était
à vireux ils ont ils ont pris deux
l'exergue du truc et là ils en ont fait
un truc esthétique parce qu'on se
sentiraient plus proches des gens qui
ont vécu les mêmes choses que nous donc
forcément si un mec avec eux des années
80 je serai plus proche de lui ok et ça
ça se rend sans tirer dans l'est pour ça
faut vraiment le connaît l'histoire elle
tenu et c'est dans la tenue je pense
qu'en fait tu te rends en fait tu te
rend très vite compte qu un mec il vient
pas des années 80 et voilà je pense
attendant je pense que je lui dirai à
lui il a un pattes d'éléphant tous les
jours on n'avait pas tous les jours avec
un point grâce que le dire sauf que si
autriche
tu vas un peu dans une friperie et tu
triches et u13 avec des mecs de l'époque
des années 80 alors que enfin pourront
ils sont beaucoup plus jeune que toi tu
regrettes tu très à l'écouté incognito
jusqu'à ce que tu meurs dans la musique
classique dans la rue non mais attends
mais ça continue c'est bien mais ça
serait un truc intéressant mais c'est le
doute sur les jambes
je pense que ce sens classique
les bretons tous moi je pense que c'est
donc sur les gens il ya des gens qui
t'ont je resterai
mais je pense que lui sommant ce doute
sur les gens fait que ça créerait une
envie de savoir l'âge des gens j'ai trop
n'aurait qu'un mec tu te dirai il a pas
l'air d'être en mode années 90 et à kehl
offre 27 hockey mais je pense que c'est
un truc hypra tabou au combelles alors
ce serait grave justement je pense que
si on a tous la même apparence il y
aurait pu vraiment de questions d'âge
est ce que au final si on avait tous à
l'apparence large ce serait vraiment
problème ou au moins une thématique là
quand on rencontre quelqu'un en soirée
tu dis bonjour comment tu t'appelles tu
fais quoi dans la vie tu as quel âge est
souvent moment deuxième phrase c'est à
quel âge est ce que si on se ressemble
tous doré cette question je vous le
répète plus assez marrant ça oui c'est
déjà laissé là c'est vraiment un rôle
clé dans sa guerre
bah oui cas si on a tous le même âge en
apparence selon toi on se demanderait
encore plus l'âge
ouais or un autre âge aujourd'hui il est
plus ou moins marqué sur nos têtes mais
je sais que tu as la fontaine enfin 25
30 du coup si j'y reste
c'est marqué sur ta tête mais on te
demande colle si jamais c'était pas
marqué sur ta tête tu penses qu'on
demanderait encore plus ouais parce que
justement aucun moyen de savoir
oui mais pourquoi tu as besoin de savoir
si jamais tout le monde a la même tête
et tout le monde a le même truc parce
que tu adaptes ton discours s'adapte
tout ce que tu vas faire tout ce que tu
veux dire à la personne en fonction de
son âge aussi tu vois tu disais tu vas
genre j'ai besoin de savoir son âge pour
savoir de quoi je lui parlais comme
angers lui parler quel concept vraiment
quelle forme de respect aussi je te lui
adresser un seul plein plein de trucs tu
vois si on était jeunes jusqu'à sa mort
il y aurait beaucoup plus de couple avec
des écarts de comptage tu joues au métal
à moi je pense que de tous les trucs
c'est le truc qui sera le plus vrai ça
parce que c'est déjà un peu le cas enfin
là il ya déjà pas grand chose qui
empêche un mec de 40 ans de sortir
qu'une image de banque et si ces
empêcheurs de certains acquis neufs de
80 ans
bâle là dans ce monde vas-y quoi là il y
aurait plus rien fait parce qu'en fait
le chou les relations et le sexe et tout
ça c'est des trucs ou hausse mais le
monde maria leurs limites en amitié on a
plus tendance à qu'on a des amis
beaucoup plus larges du conte à plus de
tranches d'âge etc
on n'a plus d'amis qu de conquête
normalement tu as 45 ans tu seras le
king de 19 ans est attrayante et oui je
vous linverse exact exactement il disait
que j'allais dire excellent mais c'était
pas la commune différemment si tu sais
si tu savais que c'est pas ça sert pas
s'arrêter tirage si le remake de 91 ans
et que tu veux un enfant et qu'il te
manque
tu sais quoi ben non mais attends et et
pourquoi la france et tous les joueurs
stérile avec tu sais pas pourquoi
pourquoi on part du principe que des
gens m'ont tiré sur l'âge parce qu'ils
montrent déjà sur leur âge alors qu'ils
ont mené des plans de gens montent sur
la grille mais pour y tuer
renseignements sur tous ces livres c'est
bien soudée s'il vous plaît un petit peu
de sérieux
ouais c'est si on devait rester jeunes
jusqu'à la mort qu'on pourrait dire
adieu à la catégorie milf
c'est très regrettable du coup il aurait
là il y aurait la catégorie performance
on sait qu'ils ont 20 ans du coup ça
fait leur avis mais ça serait dommage
pour ce qu'elle à la 81 800 magasins
puis ça a l'air bonne mais elle n'a pas
d'énergie
il ya ceux qui t'offre du sexe en live
et tu payes avec mbia et d'un coup et
mercredi elle avait 80 ans j'ai vraiment
donné quatre normales tout ça
réponse de l'est à kaboul je pense que
vieillir physiquement permet d'accepter
petit à petit la mort aussi de prendre
du recul sur sa vie de la voir se
dessiner sur son corps je pense aux
rides pour son entourage c'est pareil en
voyant vieillir ses grands parents et
parents on accepte petit à petit l'idée
qu'ils vont nous quitter
si on restait jeunes jusqu'à sa mort ce
serait un choc beaucoup plus fort et
marquant s'est pas terminée d'un autre
côté on n'aurait pas hésité entre je
voyage en étant jeune puis je fais des
enfants où je fais des enfants et j'en
profite pleinement après question qui
occupe pas mal d'esprits nous précise
léa qu'avant enfin on dit que la mort
fait partie de la vie mais je pense que
vieillir aussi il faut l'accepter
énorme salle revient revient fait tout
mais l'aggravation sur les rides et 1
devrait évidemment ça prépare non
c'était très touchant ce qui adviendra
et c'est vrai que c'est vrai bah en fait
ça fait bad et je pense quand tu
vieillis tu vois je pense que les
cymbales on gagne ou on est du coup la
voix 6 à rabat dont tu as besoin en
verre je pense que ton n'aurait pas
besoin
mais le moment où tu être persuadé que
c'est vraiment la façon que l'annoncent
de maladie par exemple tu as d'autant
plus de mal à l'accepter je pense que tu
étais personnel d'être un peu jeune
la question en plus sous jacente pour
moi c'est qu'est-ce qui nous qu'est-ce
qu'on sous-entendu salem qu'est ce qui
nous aidera à savoir que quelqu'un va
mourir bientôt quoi maintenant que toi
tu le sais qu est ce qui nous aidera à
nous préparer
toi tu sais pas par une chute et toi tu
te sens tu sens j'avais en fait 90 ans
ça voudrait dire qu'un type amnésique
n'aurait aucun moyen de connaître son
âge
du coup il pourrait mourir n'importe
quoi hall à venir
c'est ce à quoi est-ce que vous avez
passez un bon bref c'est très cool et g
kwh m an ce qui est bien c'est l'arbre
moi je reste dedans je pense que ça
coince
je pense qu'il y aurait plus de suicides
vieux fait mais j'ai envie de rester
dedans
pardon la prochaine fois je fais c'est
ce qui fait que autant de meuf que tu
connais sa porte parce que tu
accepterais par l'allemand celui-ci
devant le voisin épisode redresser dole
pour le prochain épisode la question à
laquelle il faut répondre plus pour la
prochaine fois vous invite à répondre en
commentaire de cette vidéo
t'imagines si la france était un état
des états unis d'amérique
je serai avec ma famille qui vit aux
états unis et encore merci pour toutes
vos réponses sur cet épisode 7 et hop
vous attend pour le prochain bisous on a
changé d'âge on a gardé la même
apparence saurez vous deviner quel âge
nous avons vraiment 15 secondes de plus
qu'il ya 15 cibles et le gp est en fait
disponible est de contrôler et qui
s'appelle savoir bien vite je vous m
description de la vidéo les liens si
vous voulez retrouver
buts à nice détailler otis et freddy
gladieux un truc que j'ai pas suivi
merci d'être venu ici ce paysagiste et
j'ai été atteint mais on se retrouve
pour un rouge et l'épisode très bientôt
[Musique]
tu l'avais la piste en monodose c'est
fait ça on sait qu'il est vieux j'avais
ça je ne peux pas les règles c'était le
bon